foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
he Declassified him with his mind sure
of it
absolutely positively sure
Biden the second the second he took the
oild of office he used his mental
capacity
to declassify those documents and by the
way they're his they're his they're his
documents
they have his name on them they're
they're his he owns them
how in the world could he ever get in
trouble for these occupants and oh by
the way by the way I want to tell you
a little plot twist here he is the
president United States sir he's immune
from all crimes
he cannot be prosecuted for any crimes
whatsoever
he has immunity to everything and by the
way this was a perfect perfect closet a
perfect lock and also also I want to
tell you
that President Biden while he had these
documents
as the vice president former vice
president he had Secret Service detail
it was almost as if they were protected
listen if if you're in the threads with
these moglodytes these Trump humping
fools about these classified documents
absolutely mock them
make fun of them they've lost the plot
if they're if they
if they're narrative now is going to be
prosecute and indict
a president of the United States for
having some classified documents in the
lock closet somewhere where they're not
supposed to be oh my god let's do that
you goddamn right let's prosecute the
[ __ ] out of anyone who has one two two
hundred twelve hundred documents
in a closet they're not supposed to be
in [ __ ] yes what's criminally indict
those people let's lock them away and
put them in gitmo you are goddamn right
I am all for that I don't know if you
noticed
but their mango Mussolini Jesus
has lost the plot on these classified
documents
and the reason why they do this is
because they do not have any sort
of idea of what reality and facts truly
are they have no [ __ ] clue they are
so untethered from The Real World
and what is possible in the Department
of Justice and what is and what isn't
crime with intent
that they have lost the plot on the
classified documents
I mean we were told for we've been being
told for months and months and months
that they're his documents he
Declassified them they're not even
they're not even classified documents
anymore because he declass so it's not a
crime it's not a crime he had him locked
away there was a lock there was a lock
they were protected they were protected
by the Secret Service and all kinds of
nonsense on and on and on it goes
and we knew it was all a bunch of
[ __ ]
and now you're gonna see the [ __ ]
right out in the open again
because they're going to they're going
to make claims against the current
president of the United States that
somehow he should be impeached and
jailed and sent to gitmo and hang for
crying out loud I'm sure they'll get
there I mean it's a q Anon World we're
just living in it [ __ ]
they're gonna get there there's gonna be
all kinds of crazy ass [ __ ] the facts
remain though
Joe Biden more than likely had these
documents for his memoir
that's that's normal normally normally
when a government official has documents
that's part of their archive that have
any classifications on them those
documents are meant
for information for them to recall more
than likely this office was used by the
former Vice President Joe Biden
the moment the moment his attorneys real
attorneys not some [ __ ] ambulance
Chasers who were going to lose their law
license because they're [ __ ] frauds
and phonies
the moment his attorneys found these
documents they immediately notified Nara
they immediately notified the Department
of Justice they immediately notified the
White House counsel the White House
Council turned him over immediately the
same [ __ ] day
that's not obstruction
oh listen listen to me do not be scared
of this Joe Biden's document story this
story is gold
the way they reacted is gold and don't
don't go into this [ __ ] I've heard
this this morning from the media because
the media has always got to be like oh
well hell is this gonna hell is this
gonna affect Joe Biden how's it going to
affect the Democrats are they going to
lose the 2024 race because Joe Biden had
two classified dog oh my God
the media is a bunch of [ __ ] hacks do
not listen to them
and if you're in the media out there
acting like that this is a this is a big
[ __ ] story and somehow this changes
the narrative you are a dumb
[ __ ]
I'm telling you right now and if you if
you are in the media and you're a
journalist and you want to challenge me
come on the show let's do it I'll talk
to you I'll tell you how it is come on
let's do this
dumbest [ __ ] thing I've ever heard in
my life
that you know the facts that the media
knows the facts and they're like well
why didn't we know this at the time
who gives a [ __ ] what what what
entitles the media to have every single
piece of information in the moment
what
what entitles them to that it doesn't oh
well this happened days before the
election who gives a flying [ __ ] who
gives a flying rat's ass when it
happened and if it happened two days
before the election so you're telling me
because the White House went you know
it's right before an election We're not
gonna we're gonna sit on this for a day
the [ __ ] out of here with this nonsense
the media is mad
that they couldn't [ __ ] Spin The
Narrative to try to get Republicans to
win more seats in the Senate
they didn't get to spend the narrative
so the Republicans took over more of our
[ __ ] government
I don't know if you've noticed but ever
since they've taken over our government
in the last day they've absolutely
destroyed the Ethics Committee you know
that swamp they're talking about
that they want to drain
they just put a plug in the drain you
stupid bastards and I told you this
would happen
the most corrupt group of [ __ ]
in our country's history have now taken
over the Congress
and the first thing they did the first
thing was absolutely make sure that they
can get nothing done that's that's folks
that's
a [ __ ] feature
of their party
they are obstructing themselves with the
rules
they're making sure that they cannot get
business done
they're only going to make it appear as
if they're doing things they don't want
to actually do things
the 72-hour rule
there are 435 members of Congress
okay
the reason why
the House of Representatives has proxy
voting
is because it is damn hard to get all
400 Plus members on the house floor at
any given time
we watched that happen last week that is
why the House of Representatives uses
proxy boating it is much easier for the
Senate who does not have proxy voting to
get a hundred people on the floor to
vote for something I don't know if you
know I don't know numbers and math
but that's just how humans work and math
works
so not only can Kevin McCarthy not count
votes because we witnessed this on
Friday when he thought he was going to
win in the first vote and he lost him
and Matt Gantz almost had a fist fight
over it and then they had to have
another vote to fulfill his promise to
the media that he'd be speaker
giving away God knows what maybe it was
the Ethics Committee that no Republican
could ever be questioned on ethics
whatsoever because if they are they're
[ __ ]
so this idea that George Santos is going
anywhere he's not going anywhere folks
that [ __ ] is gonna be a member
of Congress for two [ __ ] years as
long as he can stand the media chasing
him down the hallways that's that's how
long before Santos has a mental break or
the Department of Justice [ __ ]
indicts him and jails him that's the
question
they don't know how to govern
they don't they only know how to
obstruct and it is clear in this rules
package that their only goal is to
obstruct that is it I mean Jesus Christ
you look at this stupid [ __ ] IRS
thing oh my God they are such dumb bucks
it it almost feels like they thought
and their constituents believe the
[ __ ] lies that Fox News and all the
trader TV news networks told them it's
almost like the lies that they told
about the 87 000 IRS agents they believe
because they're all [ __ ] lies
every [ __ ] one of them
the government didn't hire 87 000 people
to the IRS in two months
nor can they take back the funding it's
already [ __ ] appropriated to the IRS
nor can they demand that the IRS not
hire agents this is stupid [ __ ] [ __ ]
the the IRS is not part of the
legislative branch
got it and they could [ __ ] they can
[ __ ] pass all kinds of legislation
and all kinds of [ __ ]
trying to strong-arm the IRS but the
fact remains
the reason why they do not want the IRS
to have staff is because that would take
away money from their donors which takes
away money from them
that's how it works uh politics girl has
a video someone pointed it out to me
this morning I think we might play that
when we get Texas Paul on here see what
his reaction is to this IRS thing oh my
God or 87 pounds oh my God we're gonna
we're gonna make sure to kill 87 000
jobs that weren't actual yeah Jesus
again this is what you get though
when you put people in charge of
government that are not Tethered to
[ __ ] reality they're just not they
won't be
so if you start from the point
of criticizing and judging
these Republicans based on reality you
were doing it wrong I'm telling you I I
know it feels like oh there's so much
stuff and it's so many lies
right
it's also a feature of their party
but we have to keep the plot going we
have to keep the narrative going because
they're losing grip of it
they're totally losing grip of it
I mean maybe just maybe
maybe just maybe we should encourage the
Republicans
to open a select committee on these
Biden classified documents oh my God
yes let's do that let's do that let's
have Republicans open a select committee
and Kevin McCarthy only appoint
Republicans no Democrats to this
committee
let's make sure that it's a complete
[ __ ] [ __ ] show
a kangaroo court
based on two documents they found in the
closet in the former vice president's
office that he more than likely had
these documents for his memoir
there was no obstruction they were
handed over immediately when his real
attorneys who have Wall license by the
way are still and they probably will
continue to have a license
foreign
acknowledges that they didn't even know
these documents existed
so let's have a six-month eight-month
select committee on this
app so [ __ ] lutely let's see how
inept
and how ridiculous
that the Republicans can be and let's
throw some laptop talk in there hell why
not they like to make [ __ ] up why not
make [ __ ] up more about lab that was
there a laptop in this closet I don't
know there could have been a laptop in
this closet I'm sure the lab Hunter
Biden's laptop was hiding in this locked
closet I'm sure that's where it's at
I don't know what it was doing in the
closet
but I'm sure it was there right
look if you could just make [ __ ] up
let's just make [ __ ] up
but they lost the plot
they've totally lost the plot this
morning they thought this was going to
be good too by the way like oh man Joe
Biden classified documents is gonna be a
good story oh we really don't get them
live tards we really gonna show them
and you can make every [ __ ] argument
that these
troglodytes have been making the last
six months about their [ __ ] orange
Mussolini Jesus and his crimes when he
stole
thousands of our [ __ ] classified
documents from our government to
to make sure to cover up January 6.
because I think that's the uh actual
story here folks about the documents and
the reason why Trump and his allies are
going to want you to focus on those
the reason why it's not a document's
case
this case that Jack Smith took I think
the FBI and the Department of Justice
realized really quick that the documents
case is the January 6 case
it's the same [ __ ] case
the document's case is just how they
found out more of the plot of January 6
and him trying to overturn the
government
you remember the January 6 elect
committee had a really tough time
finding
parts of the White House logs and
documents from the White House and
prison it trumps office at the time of
January 6. they just seemed to
disappeared hmm
I wonder where they disappeared to could
it be could it be
that that piece of [ __ ] garbage
stole those documents in an attempt
to make sure that the American people us
who own those documents do not get to
see those put their eyes on them to see
what he was planning to see what he
wanted to do the same way as he didn't
want you to see his tax returns so you
didn't know how [ __ ] broke he was
it's always with this guy
every [ __ ] time
and these boneheads buy into this stuff
why because they want to
they don't want the truth
why would they want the truth
the truth does not serve
their bias it doesn't it won't
so if you expect
this 118th Congress to have any sort of
production
other than just huge steaming piles of
[ __ ]
you are out of your mind
now what can you do about it not a
goddamn thing but mock it politicize it
and make sure that us as a pro-democracy
coalition push the narrative in the
messaging for 2024 to win back the House
of Representatives
oh I have good feelings about the senate
in 2024. I have really good feelings
about the House Representatives now that
we see this rule package
I don't know I don't know if you're well
versed on house floor rules
one of the ones that stands out to me
the best and absolutely makes sure that
they're handicapped that they cannot
pass bills
is the 72-hour rule
now
Republicans for a long time have really
bitched and bitched and moaned about
ramming through big pieces of Legends
it's it's 1200 Pages you expect me and
my staff to review 1200 Pages it's like
you elected me to be a lawmaker
you [ __ ] boneheads
of course legislation is hundreds of
pages of course it is
when you're making sure that the
government is funded when you're making
sure that Appropriations are done for
the American people for all the programs
that make sure not not just including
welfare
but military have you have you seen
have you seen how many pages it takes to
fund the military you stupid [ __ ]
now this is why the 72-hour rule is
intentional to obstruct and it's
intentional to destroy our Congress the
reason why is because of a bill has to
sit there for 72 hours
before we can vote for closure
that way we can read it do you think
they're gonna read it no they're not the
[ __ ] out of here if their intention
wasn't to read it they never will read
it
this is all that tempt for them to
appear like they're keeping their
promises
but again don't pay attention to what's
real because they don't give a [ __ ]
what's real
you think Kevin McCarthy is going to
bring a bill to the floor at all no
no I I I I would I would be I would be
really [ __ ] surprised if Kevin
McCarthy brings an actual bill
like one that you know helps the
American people at all
I mean he made names the post offices
and some federal buildings after some
[ __ ] Traders I'm sure that we're
gonna get that nonsense
that'll get to the floor
but do you think for one second
that they're gonna have anything
productive come to the floor and these
[ __ ] idiots are going to take 72
hours to read and all these members of
the Republican caucus are going to show
up all at once to vote this stuff
through I'll tell you something that I
do know
I do know the Democrats are hell-bent on
making sure the Republicans own every
[ __ ] failure
and Hakeem Jeffries oh my
Hakeem Jeffries is going to put the
cherry on top
of their failure Sunday every
[ __ ] time
because there is there is one thing that
I'm impressed with with the King
Jeffries more than anything that I think
I've seen in a democratic politician in
a long [ __ ] time
dude knows messaging dude knows
narrative
and the guy knows where the caucus and
the Democratic Coalition is headed he
can see it you can see that the guy
knows the future of this country you
could see that the guy knows the future
of our democracy and who will support it
smart [ __ ] but more than
anything
being a good policy maker he's a leader
and he knows messaging and he knows
that's how you win
the I I'm telling you folks if you're
not excited about Hakeem Jeffries being
the longest serving speaker of the house
and you can make that happen you're part
of making a king Jeffries the longest
serving most effective speaker of the
house that we've had in history and that
is a big high bar against Nancy Pelosi
folks
but he gives me great hope
and yeah I talked about yesterday people
wanting a king Jeffries to be president
you're out of your mind
you have no I you have no idea the power
of that gavel when King Jeffries grabs
that gavel and he's the Speaker of the
House in 2024. oh my God
oh man
it's not it's not just the gavel it's
the podium it's the voice
it's the reach it's the it's the
microphone it's the amplifier
the power that he will have
to push forward the protemocracy
Coalition because that's the other thing
about Akeem Jeffries that I'm impressed
with
he's genuine he's authentic
and it's not surprising seeing his
background of how genuine and authentic
the man is
I'm stoked about Hakeem Jeffries
absolutely [ __ ] stoked
and I think Kevin McCarthy
it's gonna fail every [ __ ] time
against this guy oh
King Jeffries is not gonna have to work
very hard to outmaneuver Mick loser
and it's going to be fantastic I guess
we'll just see how long McCarthy is
speaker
but I'm excited and we have to stay
focused on This House of Representatives
we have to stay focused on the
Republican failure to govern why they're
inept why they're not Tethered to
reality why Q Anon is a hell of a drug
and they're on it
that is the narrative for the next two
years folks that is your focus
we're gonna talk a shitload about what
the [ __ ] they're doing in the house like
a [ __ ]
because ain't nothing gonna happen
anywhere else
that's the only place
that the failure of our government is
going to reside
and they're going to own every [ __ ]
bit of it today is Tuesday
today is Tuesday January 10th and you
know what Tuesday is Tuesday's Taco
Tuesday but it's also
the day that Texas Paul joins us
we have Texas Paul here with us today I
hope to ask him about this IRS thing see
what he thinks
see what the hell's going on also oh boy
I have to give my thoughts and pears not
really uh I'm gonna talk about this for
just a few minutes before we go to break
uh you guys know diamond and silk
you guys know this
oh excuse me for not giving a flying
[ __ ]
about someone who's been on the airwaves
talking about how vaccines don't work
and fauci's the enemy and kovid's just a
cold blah blah blah blah yakety smackity
getting covered and dying I don't give
two [ __ ] shits good [ __ ] them
at this point if you are not vaccinated
and you do not have the idea that covet
is a deadly [ __ ] disease and you are
dying from it we're we're in 2023 folks
we're damn near three years from the
point when covert reached our Shores we
know a shitload about it
a shitload about it and the one thing we
know about it has happened how how to
prevent a death from it the best you can
and Diamond dying doesn't [ __ ] break
my heart at all
doesn't break my heart at all [ __ ] her
that's right I'll piss on her grave I
don't give a [ __ ]
for that for that [ __ ] scumbag to
Condit now I'm surprised to be quite
honest and surprised that she hadn't
vaccinated and she wasn't protected and
you know maybe she was genuinely just
stupid and she believed the lies that
she was telling because I believe a lot
of these [ __ ] grifters on the right
that are telling people not to get
vaccinated or fully [ __ ] vaccinated
and boosted
they just don't want you to know it
so [ __ ] her and um silk
I wish you the uh the best of luck
couldn't happen to a better gal let me
tell you oh boy every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific right here on YouTube
Twitter and twitch if you're here today
make sure to subscribe to the YouTube
channel we're gonna try to get to 20 000
before the end of the month you think we
can do it
I don't know we're at over 13 000
subscribers on YouTube can you help me
get to 20 000 subscribers I want to tell
you a secret too before we go to break
on January 14th
2021 this show started
that was the day that they voted
for impeachment articles
for the Cheeto dust q and honor for his
Cheeto dusk 2 attempt
I carried it
that day I was watching it as it was
happening on the house floor on January
14th
2021
this is the two-year anniversary of the
Tony Michaels podcast this week
two years of Tony as the mods put it
so make sure I think we can get the 20
000. I think we might do a push here
this month since it's been two [ __ ]
year can you imagine two years of you
people listen to me God damn you're good
the best audience in the whole wide's
worlds everyone stick around we got
Texas Paul right after this break
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
back to the show
January 10th
know who we have with us
mine is my favorite
fresh from the cousin pond
Texas call is here joining us
as we bring in this Tuesday Texas ball
how are you my friend
I am wonderful my friend I am I love
your theme music man I just it just gets
me going every time gets
I'm trying to get the audience pumped
for the theme music
Darth I like the rock yeah you know it's
good stuff so what do you think about
this uh this [ __ ] rule package that
they passed it's uh something else I
didn't know that I I you know I'll give
him credit I'll give him credit Texas
but I really didn't think they'd pass
that [ __ ] but boy they were like
oh you mean we're gonna get rid of any
ethics investigations into US oh well
[ __ ] we'll vote for that some [ __ ]
today
yeah that's that's wonderful I I am
laughing my ass off about that let's
drain the swamp instead they took and
hooked up two big ass pumps to a sewage
treatment plant ran hoses right into
Congress
didn't they yeah I tell you what
well you got to forgive me I'm putting
my vacation face on I gotta open oh
you're going on look like hell I'm sorry
oh yeah brother anyways my travel month
oh my gosh are you going somewhere warm
oh yeah oh yeah U.S Virgin Islands baby
we're gonna be down there for weeks some
weeks well you heard it here the news
Texas Paul this will be his last his
last time for for a little bit because
you're going on vacation so everybody uh
share this episode right here right now
and uh get everyone on to um watch Texas
fall give us his opinion here on some of
the [ __ ] that uh Republicans are going
to try to do in the house and I mean try
Texas ball because this rule package uh
as you're going if you go through it and
look at just three or four items in this
[ __ ] rules package you know already
that not only uh our Republicans not
know how the process works in this day
and age
but they have obstructed themselves from
getting anything done on the floor I
mean this is just
um and this is just how the how in the
[ __ ] they couldn't even count votes for
speaker how are they going to count
votes when they don't have proxy voting
when they have the 72-hour rule when
they got to manage
um uh floor time they're they ain't
gonna be able to do this they're not
they're not equipped to [ __ ] run the
house in the first place but they just
made it harder to run the house it's so
stupid
you know and going back exactly it is it
is idiocy it is idiocy they're gonna
pass some stupid [ __ ] you know just to
get Democrats to vote it down because
it's so damn stupid like this whole 87
000 IRS agents saying that they keep
trying to [ __ ] their people with
they're gonna they're gonna they're
gonna put that on the floor and they'll
pass it by a vote or two they will but
it's Dead on Arrival you know what I
know it we know how government works
it'll never make it out of the house
right because the Appropriations the
Appropriations to the IRS has already
happened it's already signed into law
with the inflation reduction act that
money is already allocated to it's
already law they can't go back and and
not appropriate now they cannot
appropriate future funds in this next
two years they don't have to appropriate
them they can shut down the [ __ ]
government if they want and they
probably will
um September is going to be held that's
right well let me tell you something
September is going to be a great month
um for people in this country to see who
this Republican party truly is and how
who they give a [ __ ] about and who they
don't give a [ __ ] about and the American
people they don't give two shits about
them and then it's going to be obvious
in September that every time we do this
stupid dance about the stupid [ __ ]
debt ceiling and the CR the continuing
resolution kicking the can because we
got this stupid [ __ ] debt ceiling
thing we need to get rid of that [ __ ]
but you know that's the future time
future place
but I'm telling you they're going to be
they're going to be obvious about it
it's going to be clear they ran on it we
want to shut the government down we
don't want the government to operate and
they don't know that they are the
government it's just [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
and you know for folks that don't know
the Ethics Committee is by Statute a
bipartisan committee it's split half and
half okay
why if you're the party of drain the
swamp
if you're the party of you know in power
and you're going to say we're going to
do investigations would you not want the
Ethics Committee
doing its job
you know I mean what is unless you are
planning to do a lot of really dirty
[ __ ] why would you want a hamstring the
Ethics Committee well I mean I I think
it's because they promised George Santos
met Kevin McCarthy said you vote for me
I'll make sure you're you're a member of
Congress for two years I think that's
the deal that was made rather you're
indicted or you get criminal charges
whatever you'll be a member of Congress
as long as you can stand it because I'll
make sure to get Ethics Committee out of
your way he made that promise to Scott
Perry he made that promise to gozar he
made that promise to several other
members of Congress that are in a ham
ringer over this January 6th yet and
this uh State electors scheme that a lot
of these members of Congress were
involved in so I believe that the the
deal about the Ethics Committee
Kevin McCarthy traded that away to get
rid of the Ethics Committee that way no
one on the Republican side can be held
accountable but you're right if you
think about it you know Democrats could
do all kinds of crazy [ __ ] right now
there's no Ethics Committee to hold them
accountable why not [ __ ] because at this
committee generally speaking is 50 50.
um in in rules it's not doesn't matter
who has control of the house it's always
50 50 because it's called I don't know
ethics but they don't have any so that's
why they want to get rid of it
yeah and I think it has a lot to do with
Brooks and Biggs and Jordan and Bobo and
you know Bobo tweeting out yeah Matt
Gates you know he's about to get his ass
reamed out because his I mean his buddy
has just gone straight at dude he's just
I mean diarrhea of the mouth with the
doj
um
these guys want to eliminate the Ethics
Committee for one reason and one reason
only they have a lot of culpability
coming up uh in from both the doj and
the judicial system and they don't want
an Ethics Committee there to be able to
take these because that's how you get
somebody really removed from Congress
right you do it goes through the Ethics
Committee and they're just trying to
insulate themselves no matter how dirty
we find out they are that that we can't
get them off the floor that and that's
what these 15 votes were about folks be
quite honest with you that's what it was
about is is you have the the freedom
caucus that are out there that are ass
deep did you say the dumb caucus the
freedom College that's what I call them
yeah their income is really free it
doesn't cost a goddamn thing huh
oh God yeah but you've got them just
they're in a mess man they are
politically their ass is in a crack and
they know it and that's what that's what
this negotiations was about was
guarantees that that no matter what
happened no matter how dirty it makes
Kevin McCarthy because Kevin McCarthy
truthfully if you think about it he
doesn't want to be a dirty speaker he
doesn't want to be a weak speaker that
wasn't what was in his heart the speaker
he just wants to just have the title
yeah there's no his dream was not this
you know what I mean this was not his
dream this was it this was his only
inflection point this is it this was his
only chance
um anything past this he'd never be
known as a speaker of the house he'd
always be known as a guy who wanted to
be speaker no matter what detail is sold
to the Devil Himself you've heard that
uh song Devil Went Down to Georgia yeah
a few times I I thought um I thought
about that song a lot last last week as
they were fighting on the house floor
and wanting to punch each other
um because um you know
they just couldn't get to a corrupt deal
soon enough
um they were all rather punchable
looking individual though you know I
said this yesterday that I there's
nothing better than punching a Nazi but
Nazis punching each other I don't know
it might be I'm just saying you could
almost pay-per-view that [ __ ] I'm just
you know on that I agree with you 100 we
could [ __ ] we get you know what
Republicans thinking about this real
hard Republicans could balance the debt
I can balance the budget Texas balls
that they have to do is
um pay-per-view their their fights and
people would pay big money people would
pay big money to watch Matt Getz and uh
I don't know Andy Biggs go at it oh
hardcore
could you imagine
how much money a bobo
versus the elevator flagellator oh my
Marjorie cater green I mean those two in
a cage match oh [ __ ] and I mean that
that would break all records yeah
absolutely lock them in a cage and let
them go at it for a couple hours I'm
telling you man we could bounce the
[ __ ] budget we get rid of the deficit
all together just pay-per-view that [ __ ]
just clear the house floor of the chairs
put a wrestling ring up we're at
WrestleMania in real life already so why
not yeah I mean they're already there
huh that's the real damn shame of this
Tony it really is I mean it's it's fun
to laugh at and it and we know how
useless how weak and useless they are
but
man to drag our institutions through
this it's just a damn shame it really is
well but that was the warning that um
all of us in the pro-democracy Coalition
was trying to uh amplify for people out
there to make sure that it was so
important and they listened
um as much as you know we're in the
situation where we're in now where
they're they're holding on to this House
of Representatives by four or five votes
um they really truly are
I mean it this this majority
um that they have the slim majority that
they have it would it would be hard
enough to get anything done
as the opposition in the government uh
to the Senate and to the executive
branch uh to actually pass anything and
see any success uh with ink on a pin uh
to become law at all I mean the thought
that a republican held house in this
moment in history would actually pass a
bill that would go to the senate pass on
the floor of the Senate and uh and go to
the president's desk and he would sign
it is
I mean the chances of that the only
thing we're going to get is Government
funding and I doubt we're going to get
that in September I would honestly
believe
um that in September we're probably
going to go till January or February
mark my time stamp right now we're gonna
we're they're gonna defund the
government from September to January
February until they can't stand it no
more
um and they're going to damage the
American people they're going to damage
the American economy they're going to
damage the world economy
um they'll they'll likely want to
default on our debt which is a place
we've never been before
um in our country now defaulting on our
debt our credit rating our national
credit rating will go down which is
something that is never really happened
in our modern history that they're going
to destroy everything that they touch
and it's because that's what they want
to do they want to destroy our democracy
they've continued I have a prediction
yeah go ahead I have a prediction there
are 18
Republicans actually it's a little less
than 18 it's 16 because they did some
redistricting in Arizona they chopped up
Arizona's first but there are
theoretically they're 18. Republicans
sitting in strong pro-biden districts
many that Biden won 10 to 15 points
um these are safe for people to switch
parties they are they can switch parties
they can say you're saying
I'm a Democrat no no saying I'm an
independent is what they'll do oh yeah
they'll say they're I Kirsten Cinema is
what you're saying yeah they'll say I'm
an independent then they'll caucus with
the Democrats it only takes you know a
handful of Republicans well I I don't I
don't doubt you in that in that
prediction I'm just saying it's going to
take a lot of tension a lot of stress
and um a lot of pushback from the
American people because again the
Republicans don't give a [ __ ] about the
American people they don't care what
pressure is put on them from the
American people they really do not give
a [ __ ] as long as it doesn't affect them
personally it doesn't affect their
pocketbook and it doesn't affect their
donor's pocketbook they don't give two
shits and they'll hang on I don't know
if you'll remember this
but Trump shut down the government in
2018. and he unlocked for I don't know
about a month it's about a month that he
shut down the government longest it has
been shut down a long time and and a lot
of people uh felt felt the hurt
and I think we're gonna go there again
but we're gonna go there for a much
longer period of time and the reason why
is because Kevin McCarthy is [ __ ]
weak he's [ __ ] weak and the other
part is he has no power so he has to not
only does he have a slim majority and
now he has rules that are going to
absolutely prevent him from getting
anything on the floor done at any point
but he also is giving away all his power
to everyone else
to make sure that he has to abide by the
Maga terrorist caucus I mean and you
know you called it The free dumb caucus
I called them my guitarist caucus so uh
one example is this IRS thing this is
really stupid
um Lee McGowan politics girl did a video
on this yeah lovely she's she is so damn
sure and this is a couple minutes long
uh I think it's pretty good here of
course because it's politics girl so I'm
going to um I'm going to play Lee's uh
take your her kitchen rant here on um
defunding the IRS and then we'll talk
about it on the other side
let's be very clear the Republicans
don't want the IRS funded in fact
they've said one of the first things
they plan to land is when they regain
Park heal the funding the IRS is
receiving from the inflation reduction
act why is that because they care so
much about you the little guy the real
American and making sure we don't get
audited no the little guy gets audited
all the time in fact the IRS has told us
hundreds of times that they can only
really afford to audit the little guy
because the big dogs the ones that get
out of paying trillions of dollars a
year in taxes they have teams of
expensive lawyers that the IRS just
can't afford to compete with so they try
and make up those tax losses on the
backs of us regular people they have no
choice they keep asking for a bigger
budget to go after the real cheats but
until now they didn't have it we're
supposed to believe that the party who
voted against raising the minimum wage
and capping insulin prices and equal pay
for equal work is just suddenly looking
out for the people we're supposed to buy
that the Republicans who are running to
repeal lower prescription drug prices
and Affordable Health Care for Seniors
the party who tried a hundred different
ways to get rid of the Affordable Care
Act and who wants to phase out Social
Security and Medicare is just looking
out for us normies come on hell didn't
freeze over Republicans don't want to
fund the IRS because it'll finally have
the budget to go after their donors
their lobbyists the industries that
cheat us and support them and just so
we're clear the 87 000 IRS employees
that were proposed in the inflation
reduction act are to be hired over the
course of 10 years that number is meant
to reflect everything from the
janitorial staff to people who are
retiring during that time so there won't
be 87 000 new IRS agents ultimately
there might be around ten thousand the
goal is to make sure the department is
properly funded so they have the
resources and the Personnel to hold the
biggest tax evaders accountable who
would vote against that we leave
trillions of dollars on the table a year
trillions of dollars that would allow us
to pay for everything from
infrastructure to defense to shore up
Social Security and pay for services and
help the American people making sure the
IRS has proper funding has to do with
balancing the budget lowering our
deficit taking care of our citizens our
taxes pay for things Democrats want to
make sure you get that what you pay for
Republicans want to make sure they don't
have to pay for a single thing you get
don't let them trick you this isn't
about you it's never been about you it's
always and forever about them
use your noodle
so there you go there's Paul thanks girl
lean again and shall we spot on always
yeah he'd always pretty much count on
her just absolutely dropping the fix you
know she's got it that is why I love Lee
yeah yeah I mean the other I mean the
thing that people need to realize too is
well oh welcome Gabe welcome thank you
thank you welcome I don't know if it's
trillions I think it's up to 8 trillion
I think yesterday they were talking
about it and I think the number that
they were coming up with was like it was
like 586 billion was left untaxed on
people uh at least last year
uh but obviously as as our population
increases and our economy increases it
only makes sense to also increase the
number of IRS agents I mean I think we
have less IRS agents today than we did
in the 50s right so that's something to
think about when we had less population
less economy and the other thing too is
yes the 87 000 we've talked about before
is over the course of 10 years right
it's not like I mean if they could hire
87 000 people like that that would be
impressive right they're not going to
show up at your door they're not going
to kick it down uh it's not like you
have stolen documents like Trump uh but
the 87 000 you know if you divide by 10
simple math or Republicans it's about 8
700 per year just want to do that for
you right now but that also is replacing
around 8 000 people who cycle out
because of retirement so it's not like
wait wait you mean you mean people get
older and then it's crazy man there's
this thing called Aging and you have a
retirement plan and you got a pension uh
and they cycle out right I thought I
thought all these goddamn government
workers were were cyborgs they were they
were yeah I mean a lot of those
government employees got a lot of those
government employees got the covered
vaccine so they're running on 5G they
already tuned like a machine what do we
need 87 000 if we got all of our
government employees running on the five
and the 7g I'm just saying look this is
um there's so many facets of this that
is absolutely mockable and laughable and
they're going to continue to do this
[ __ ] the pure simple fact that this
thing even exists for Kevin McCarthy to
say the first thing we're gonna do is
repeal funding that we already
appropriated for government employees
that we can't control whether they hire
or not because they can't control really
whether the IRS replaces these agents
they can't control that I mean they can
say don't do it but the IRS is part of
the executive branch they can hire
whoever the [ __ ] they want for the
agents that they want the only thing
that Congress can do is to haul in the
head of the IRS and are you at a coffee
what the hell's going on he's got a
maggots here dude sorry oh you're at a
magnet oh you're not going to be out of
maggot I'm sorry I didn't mean to
distract I apologize no
uh here's here's here's the thing is
that this
is 70. it's awesome it's incredibly
performative is what it is oh right
because that's the point is that they
made this problem up they made up this
idea that there was 87 000 new agents
that were going to come at your door and
point a gun at you and hold out their
hand and make you give them 20 dollars
or some [ __ ] that the point is is that
it's all made up so what they do is they
make up this stupid [ __ ] problem that
doesn't exist it's a big [ __ ] lie and
then they fix it with another big
[ __ ] lie and now it's fit woohoo it's
fixed a problem that didn't exist that
we made up ooh it's fixed
to slap a little reality in this
conversation a new agent they should
they hire sharp people they really do
these are some very educated sharp
people but they call the new agents baby
agents because they're about as
effective as an infant they I want you
to think about this
recite the tax code to me
you can't do it you can't do it
the first thing
tax code these guys have to be able to
and then
show me what
criminal activity on a corporate tax
return looks like yeah good luck then
they have to teach them that then they
have to teach it takes years to bring an
IRS agent up to speed and our best our
most experienced the old Bulldogs that
know how to rip through these returns
and they said they could look at it and
say aha yeah I see this right here this
money going to the Grand Caymans we're
going to follow that money you know I
mean it's those agents are going out the
door right and the Republicans want a
crippled IRS not because of you and me I
mean Jesus think about your tax return I
mean we're all independent contractors
we have tax tax returns that are much
more complicated than your average
person and it's still only what if what
five pages four pages yeah it's Max form
you know well here's here's the thing
here's the thing also because I've done
a lot of tax returns in my life and I've
and when I say that I mean I've hired an
accountant to do it but I've I've looked
at them and they're [ __ ] foreign
language to me
um the thing that the reason why my
hiring account is because it's the same
reason why they have Auditors but a lot
of times when they're auditing are there
are these agents they're doing their
work they're not looking for Crime
they're not looking for Crime they're
looking for parts in the code that
someone filed wrong or did a clerical
error or I mean they're not that's where
a lot of these taxes fall right a lot of
the taxes fall in in these individual
returns that Miss a few things here and
a few things there that because they're
using HR black or and Jackson Hewitt and
I'm not knocking them but I am
um they don't know what they're doing
um anyways or if you're you know doing
well also I mean turbo that's a whole
other discussion that's right the whole
industry is built around the whole
industry now here's the thing the
government knows exactly what you owe
right you should be paying how much
money was taken out each time literally
there's a there's a system in place so
when you [ __ ] up that's what you [ __ ] up
yeah well no well they do because here's
what happens well especially if somebody
oh I you know if I'm doing it myself or
whatever oh I've just put the wrong zero
sum or whatever it might be
they know because you know typically
they'll be like a very there'll be like
a a skim through audit up this doesn't
you know this doesn't pass the the kind
of like sniff test so we need you to
provide uh additional documents but the
whole industry if people don't know this
like this could be a an incredibly
automated and efficient way if we relied
on just issuing this as an automatic hey
this is what you owe and don't worry
about these other things right like the
rest of the First World countries do
exactly right but we live in a country
where we have lobbyists that tell like
from Turbo Tax or h r block or wherever
you know those guys tax accounting spot
says Hey Congress uh don't do it this
way you need to make sure that we can
make money and by doing that we need to
make this industry where you need us
right we're going to create a problem
that you need us and now we are stuck in
a situation where you have to go to
these little brick and mortar or buy
your Turbo Tax online or whatever it
might be and then you start filling
something out and they say oh actually
you had this this year then you need
this form right you need to buy the
49.99 upgrade for this other thing so
then you end up spending hundreds of
dollars when you really didn't need to
spend any money at all outside of what
you owed that year
and that's what it is and then the other
thing the other thing I want people
understand out there and a lot of people
I don't I don't know if you know this or
not but uh our tax
um system to
um disclose what taxes you have is all
voluntary now most people don't when you
volunteer it it's because you're filling
out
uh a a form when you go get employed
that you're you're you're basically
allowing that employer which is by law
the employer has to disclose it
um what the what the tax is on your
income but in general generally speaking
just like people don't know that we the
people are the government they don't
know that our tax system when you're
declaring your income it's voluntary
it's voluntary and that's the purpose of
the IRS and the purpose of the agents is
to make sure that everyone paid their
taxes appropriately it's not necessarily
the sniff out crime and they they have a
Criminal Division at the IRS which Texas
Paul said and and those agents in the
Criminal Division are not the 87 000
agents that they're hiring some of them
will become part of that Criminal
Division right but they'll have to
become really good agents and really
good at sniffing out crime and really
good at reading tax returns most of the
Criminal Division that is hired at the
IRS aren't aren't just at low level
clerks these are [ __ ] people who went
to school as tax attorneys and they're
the ones that are snipping out the crime
a lot of them come from being
prosecutors
um and they go work at the IRS in the
Criminal Division because in generally
speaking and I know this is [ __ ]
crazy but generally speaking people do
not commit tax crime on a regular basis
most of the country the the people who
do commit tax crime are people who have
more money not less of it that are the
those are the people who are committing
tax crime like there was a guy ran for
president he may have won on a
technicality in 2016. I forget this
guy's name or you yeah I think you're
talking about uh uh little little
crybaby right yeah there's that guy yeah
yeah man child down in Mar-A-Lago but
also those people are hiring other
people to figure out the loopholes to
know I mean you know uh to know the tax
code just as well if not better than the
IRS to say huh look if we just mark this
form here but then we just put a bunch
of pass-through companies then we
shifted over here then we do this you
know it's exactly I mean like Trump had
over 500 uh pass-through companies in
his which again it's not it's not not
unusual but it's not illegal 500 500 is
a lot when you're trying to hide money
to be like here's a shell company here's
a shell company we're just going to pass
money through these well the other the
other thing is the other thing that that
speaks on that when they have shell
companies is what he's trying to do is
is trying is trying to
um get rid of liability now rather it be
legal liability or financial liability
because we know the guy doesn't pay his
bills so you would open up shell
companies when you don't decide to pay a
bill that's invoice to that company that
company just goes bankrupt yeah it's
just that companies up it's gone that
you know I don't know that company
didn't have any money anymore to pay the
bill that you want paid
um and they protect through different
entities so it doesn't come back to him
personally so he doesn't shout to Shell
out the money that's another [ __ ]
reason but um also also I want to um
talk about if you've ever seen a
billboard in Texas ball I'm sure you've
seen these Billboards there's a big
billboard it's like you got tax problems
call call Jay something another uh I
used to be an IRS agent because that's
what happens a lot of time too with the
87 IRS agents is these people go work at
the IRS they figure out what the IRS
does right these attorneys they go
figure out what the IRS does how they
audit tax returns and then they go into
the private sector trying to actually
help people who who did do something uh
wrong on their taxes or who didn't who
didn't file their taxes and then what
they do is they charge those folks to
help them with their problems with the
IRS because now that attorney knows the
IRS so there's that too uh and there's
thousands thousands they call it going
over to the dark side right that's what
they call it
so so this idea this idea that somehow
the government just hired seven thousand
agents in a couple days trained them up
and now they got guns and badges and
they're coming to your house and
knocking down your door is [ __ ] dumb
it's a made-up thing and of course it's
made up it is the Republicans
um but this is what they do is they lie
they [ __ ] lie and they lie and they
lie
um just like uh old Santos and I want to
show you another video here um boy
they're chasing him down the [ __ ]
hallways this while you're looking for
that let me throw you a quick one out
there I know a guy I know a guy that was
terrified of being audited he had a
small business and he was just terrified
of being audited there's a fantastic
write-off for for contractors if you buy
a vehicle that's over 6 000 pounds in GW
GW GVWR
you can depreciate that building that
that that vehicle the first year you buy
it
100 percent
so if you have a fantastic year and you
can't come up with enough expenses go
buy a truck
that's why Escalades I want a Cadillac
Escalades are so popular because they're
100 right off the first year I want I
want to I want to be clear we're not
accountants on this shows
but this is where I'm going with this go
ahead go ahead go ahead this is where
we're going with this though okay so he
got audited and he's like oh my God I'm
gonna lose my ass this hat and the other
he didn't he didn't because he was being
as honest as he could be with his with
his taxes and he ended up hiring a tax
attorney well the tax attorney handled
his audit where yeah he was short a few
I had to pay a few thousand bucks but he
set him up a system that was completely
legal within the law not cheating and
this guy was letting tens of thousands
of dollars of deductions per year
vaporized because he didn't know the tax
code
and the accountant he hired was just
like you call you know these you know
you're making fun of Jackson Hewitt
you're making fun of you know they're
not done they don't know your business
I'm not making fun of them I'm saying
they're [ __ ] it's a scam that's what
I'm saying so this audit which this guy
still talks [ __ ] about to this day
that put tens of thousands of dollars in
his pocket every freaking year because
the IRS doesn't care which way an audit
goes They Don't Really Care
all they care is that it's accurate
that's all they care is it accurate you
know a lot of audits with just Joe
schmoes they end up looking and say hey
man you shorted yourself 200 bucks
here's a 200 chat right they really do
that folks
the other thing too about the tax uh the
tax companies these corporations like uh
Turbo Tax
um Jackson Hewitt H R Block most of the
returns that they're doing you can
actually go to the IRS website and
submit it just like they do I mean it it
really is not that you don't even need
to Turbo Tax you can go directly to the
IRS website well that's assuming you
know well you know but again if you just
have your W-2 and if you if you're if
you're a simple like 10 40 Easy right no
problem right if you just go to the IRS
website to pay them any kind of [ __ ]
money to do the same thing as a scam and
it's all a scam on their end and the
majority of Americans do not file
anything but a 1049 easy like you're
talking about they don't they don't file
a Schedule C or Schedule E they just
don't do it most people are getting a
W-2 most people don't have enough
deductions uh to to reach the just the
general deduction of a household I mean
it just uh again it's it it's a scam and
it's but it's set up that way and that's
why the government's saying hey we need
funding do you have IRS agents because
here's the other side of the coin if you
do go to an accountant if you do have a
real accountant out there that not
that's some dude at h r block or some
Gallup Jackson Hewitt a real accountant
out there a CPA if you go to them and
you ask them hey do you have a special
number where you can get a hold of the
IRS because I can't get a hold of them
they're going to tell you hail no here's
what accountants do I'm not [ __ ] you
this is a thing in accountants offices
right now in this country and they do it
every day especially during tax time
they they do it all the time they have a
room generally speaking and has three or
four phones in it and they are on the
line with the IRS
for those for those for those phones on
hold waiting for someone to pick up the
phone so that they can talk to someone
at the IRS and they let those phones sit
on hold for hours and hours a day while
they wait for the IRS and the reason why
isn't because the IRS doesn't want to
answer the phone there's no one to
answer the goddamn phone there's no one
to help us out us the people
make sure that we get our questions
answered when it comes to us filing our
taxes we would expect any agency no
matter what it is to actually answer our
call and answer our questions about a
form that they are forcing us to file
you would expect that but there is not
an expectation with Republicans because
they're weak they're feeble they're
obstructionists and they don't know how
to govern they don't know how to
administrate they just don't and they
don't know that the IRS is our
government it's us it's our [ __ ]
Revenue Service that makes sure that
they get paid even you [ __ ] scumbags
it's just insane and the bottom line is
what what Gabe's been saying here is is
these agents aren't here for you they're
not here for you they are here because
corporations file taxes and it is
literally truckloads
of forms it is it is literally dreams
and Reams and reams of paper and you
need talented people that understand how
these things are structured in jobs that
can actually audit these situations
because corporations when they cheat on
their taxes it's to the tune of billions
of dollars you know I I ran into a guy
one time
um through a friend of mine and uh and
we were talking it was during tax time I
think and we were talking about this and
he said you know what I haven't file tax
in like seven or eight years I'm like
what he's like yeah I haven't filed
taxes like seven or eight years and I
said what do you do and he said well I'm
a contractor and I do this and I get a
1099 I'm like well you should go see an
accountant
and he went and saw the account he
didn't make a lot of money he had a lot
of deductions now he had a lot in fines
but he worked it out with the IRS they
didn't put him in prison they didn't
lock him away because he didn't go
that's that's the [ __ ] farce here is
that the Criminal Division of the IRS
isn't going to go arrest someone who
doesn't have hardly the income to even
file the goddamn return but the crime
that they're looking for is fraud that's
what they're looking for they're not
looking for someone who just doesn't do
their their what they're supposed to do
in file they're not looking for someone
who mistakenly wrote something on the
wrong line or took a deduction of
something that really wasn't the
deduction or missed a deduction they're
not they're not gonna the Criminal
Division isn't looking for that
but they are looking for the rich
[ __ ] and the frauds speaking of
of frauds and people who may or may not
commit Financial crimes have you watched
the media chase this [ __ ] around
the capitol
um
they chased him yesterday yeah at the
elevator I think this is it this is the
video yeah it might be let's watch this
you're accused of fascinating almost
every single part of your life
I'm sorry Mr Sanchez there's some
campaign Finance concerns and questions
and about your background okay um here's
here's here's the thing this guy I don't
know who this kid is right here who is
these bugs holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
the microphone's on Miss Texas boy oh
boy yeah here here there we go
um the um I don't know who this kid is I
really don't
um but boy he's got a set of nuts on him
did you gotta be one tough [ __ ]
I'm walking around following Santos and
then getting on the elevator to block
him from reporters he got to be one son
of a [ __ ] this is the like it's crazy
to think that this story started in 2022
right it's also crazy to think that no
one got opposition research on him
during the midterms which is like what
the this is crazy
but obviously once the story broke then
it was a just a complete flood like the
floodgates opened up they just like tore
open and it was just like next day next
day next day you know every day like
this insane story gets more insane every
day we find out that one of them was
pretending to be
um
uh what was it it was uh McCarthy's
Kevin McCarthy's Chief of Staff exactly
which is insane which is crazy what what
yeah so here let me let me what the [ __ ]
is this I mean he's looking that up just
the cliff notes of it is that
Santos's Chief of Staff pretended to be
McCarthy's Chief of Staff then he called
McCarthy's biggest donors and told them
hey you need to send money to the Santos
guy as as McCarthy's team is that this
is fantastic so the guy that's called
fraud so you're saying so you're saying
he's not just a fraud everyone around
him is a fraud so maybe I'm mistaken
maybe this guy in the red die maybe he
maybe he's got bigger kahunis than I
think he's going to do all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] it says uh so this new report
came out the identity of a staffer from
George Santos who allegedly impersonated
the New York house or the new house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy uh solicit
donations from wealthy people and was
paid nearly one hundred thousand dollars
by the the Santos campaign is Sam uh
Miley Miley I don't [ __ ] care the
guy's a fraud hey man if you're if
you're gonna pretend to be a chief of
staff you better get Chief of Staff type
paper so he was claiming to be Dan Meyer
in order to leverage McCarthy's Aid
influence and Usher large sums of of oh
[ __ ] he was using his own he was using
the the action he was pretending to be
McCarthy Chief of Staff like oh she said
it'd be like hey you should send this
guy give him money give him money
um it's it's every day I mean the other
thing too that people need to realize is
uh he doesn't have an office in New York
he doesn't have a campaign office that
you're legally supposed to have he
doesn't have the staff there to actually
have people come in and be like hey I
want to you know say something to Santos
okay well he's you know at the capitol
or whatever but like why does he even
show up at the Capitol at this point I
mean he's they I mean they voted for the
they voted for speaker they voted for a
rules package he should just go home to
New York New York and never return to
Washington DC what's the point
I I think I think honestly he's trying
to hide from constituents and he's also
trying to put himself in a more boy you
gotta go back to his goddamn District he
can go wherever he wants he'll go right
right go to Florida Miami go to go to
Mar-A-Lago hell you'll you'll find a lot
of like like people down there at
mar-a-locka here's here's the straight
skinny of it he is in deep legal
Jeopardy in Brazil they are going to
process keep prosecute him in abstentia
because they have found him they know
who he is they're moving forward with
the case he's going to be convicted in
Brazil of stealing his boss his wife's
boss's paycheck or checkbook well but
that ain't gonna make a hell of beans
worth the difference Texas Paul if they
don't exercise the Justice charges him
that's where I'm going with this he is
they're gonna request to extradite him
that puts the Biden Administration in a
really shitty position because if they
actually do extradite him then any
country that comes up with any charges
can now Yank A person of Congress and
have them extradited so what's going to
end up happening is the Biden
Administration is going to have to
protect George Santos from being
extradited to Brazil
and as long as he can hold on to his
seat
and he will because that's the reason
why they smashed up the Ethics Committee
is so that these morons who are
committing crimes that are going to be
charged and indicted with crimes can
keep their seats while they're indicted
and they will do anything for Kevin
McCarthy the scummiest of [ __ ] including
standing there with your white power
emblem and all the [ __ ] that Kevin
McCarthy once done but can't do himself
he will make George Santos do I want to
talk about that because we haven't
talked about that and um you bring up
the white power thing the the picture of
it here here's my take on it I think
that picture's all [ __ ] I really I
honestly you know it's a great narrative
if George Santos is some kind of [ __ ]
Nazi and white supremacist and all that
[ __ ] I get it but that that picture that
picture is a is a moment in a movement
is what it is he I'm telling you he had
his hands crossed as he did the entire
time he was on the floor of the house he
had his fingers down he raised his hand
his hand was just in that position he
wasn't flashing a white power sign and
for anyone out there and I I I I'm gonna
push back on the Texas ball here because
I'm telling you I'm telling you that
does to act like that's the biggest
[ __ ] thing that George Santos is
going to do here George Santos we talked
about it before is no [ __ ] no outlier
in the Republican party with his lies
the only thing that he has done Texas
Paul is to make sure two appropriate
every single one of their lives he
didn't just do what Republicans do and
pick out one or two that he really likes
and go with those he's like I like oh
[ __ ] let's do every single [ __ ] lie
every single Beach fraud that we can do
all at once and that's why that's why he
seems like he's such a fraud but he's
not special he's a republican he's a
[ __ ] Republican and you don't need to
go very far to know how crooked these
people are and really honestly for the
internet to take a moment where he
happened to have his hand like this
because I got my hand like this right
now and that doesn't mean white power to
me
but in that moment when you're doing
that like that I'm telling you it's the
wrong narrative I I don't mean to push
back on you a bit here what about no but
what about when he picked his nose Tony
well what about when he was creeping he
went home like the fake son Nester that
Matt Gates owns I mean has in his house
you know those are moments that I say
this guy I mean like no there's there's
a lot of there's a lot of Michael
there's a lot a lot of mockable moments
and these these moments that are gonna
happen in the in the corridors of
Congress if he stays in DC are going to
be the mockable moments to take to take
an image of when he raised his hand
because he was doing this and he raised
his hand to vote that's what happened
and he just happened to have his hand in
that position
um yeah no that's not now he had it
upside down like this and I will be
honest with you I think you [ __ ] it
wasn't a movement it wasn't a through
movement on it I'll disagree with you on
this because the staffers he's got
around him
give me the video of it not the picture
the video I want the video all right I
don't want the [ __ ] that's still
image I want the video because
a lot of people do this okay sign they
put this is a speech thing this is a a
visual language thing just because a
bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] Nazis have
taken the okay symbol and they do it in
pictures like like Kyle Rittenhouse did
now if you go back and you look at the
video or the pictures of Kyle
Rittenhouse he's in a bar and they're
posing for a picture with that sign that
is different than someone using it while
they're speaking or while they're making
a movement or something like that it's
completely different and it for us to
not acknowledge that it's different that
every time you do this while you're
speaking that that somehow you're
flashing a white power sign is [ __ ]
ridiculous now it because if we can't
get past that we can't [ __ ] pin up
the George Santos or the fraud
Republican then he truly is and I hate
the best matter this point but I really
do hate that we have that I've seen
people spend
um days Days on this George Santos white
power sign that somehow he's some sort
of white supremacist because frankly you
don't have to go much further than him
supporting the Republican party than him
believing white supremacy and him
believing white supremacist ideas that's
as far as you need to take it you don't
need to find some screenshot with him
with the goddamn white power sign you
got the clip here yeah yeah okay maybe
here's the weather I mean yeah watch the
video but also it's
I look at this as an opportunity where
it's like yeah well you know what I'm
I'm I'm still gonna say it right because
I say politicize everything right yeah
right well why not right but the problem
is is this is not real this is not real
in in other words if he really did do
this like in a picture with someone I
would politicize the [ __ ] out of it but
the picture that you're seeing is not
real see he's got his hands crossed here
I was right I haven't seen this clip
I've not seen the video of this I
haven't I think we're going to end up
agreeing to disagree on this one Tony
he does his [ __ ] on purpose
Santos
McCarthy
you see that he's got that he's got that
in place ready to go
dance house
it is I think I think he's got his
fingers he's inside his elbow it's it I
mean when you cross your elbows how do
you hold it like this right
right but I think he's got his fingers
up inside his elbow like this and when
he raises his hand it shows like this
I'm telling you I'm telling you if if
it's if it's intentional that smug ass
look on his face he knew it well let me
let me tell you something let me tell
you something about George Santos that I
know is that he is a fraud a phony and a
[ __ ] liar
um for sure because he is Republican he
is Republican and it's clear on that now
a lot of people give me all kinds of
[ __ ] because I'm taking the stance but
here's what I'm saying is that I would
much rather mock him for the [ __ ] in in
the in the corridors in the hallways
that we can see where he's trying to
avoid real questions from reporters then
maybe he did maybe he didn't maybe he
had his hands crossed a certain way
maybe he tried to flash it maybe he's
singing signals because to be honest
with you this guy is a scared little
[ __ ] he's a scared little boy
go ahead let me back you up with this
one okay there's another situation up in
Omaha there's this this this uh uh there
are gun dealerships that specifically
deal with police departments okay there
are gun shops that do that there's one
up in Omaha called 1088 tax or pardon me
88 tactical
um everybody has had a fit because the
Omaha police department traded them 45
000 worth of equipment in exchange for
thirty five hundred dollars worth of
equipment and they're saying well it's
88 tactical and you know what 88 means
in white supremacist terms right right
Heil Hitler right okay that's not what
this place is named after the guy that
founded it is a cop a 1088 in Omaha or
code 88 in total and Omaha's Police
Department means all secure
so he named his company after that code
all secure tactical because he has a
security a security company
that he also runs in parallel with this
gun shop that's all secure cap that is
88 security which is all secured that's
where that comes from but everybody
makes this thing about oh it's white
supremacist because it says 88 well
that's not the case and we're doing
exactly what you're saying Tony stepping
on our deck on that one because it's not
what it means you know so I I totally
get your point I totally get your point
I disagree with you and I think that
little smug prick did it on purpose but
I know what you're saying but I totally
agree with you I I can't I can't get
behind that that [ __ ] [ __ ] had any
kind of conscious thought when he was
you know
stamping on the floor basically I mean
the guy didn't even know where the [ __ ]
he was at most the time he didn't even
know the rules he didn't know what was
happening he'd never watched he'd never
watched and never been briefed on how a
[ __ ] a congressional Hearing in the
floor operates it was clear on that
because he was looking around like what
the [ __ ] and I I just don't believe it
but here's what I do okay go ahead I was
going to say just a quick note the I
what I will say about ADA tactical is
the connection with Brazil now that's a
whole other thing that people can go
into and re and read about in terms of
what just happened this past weekend and
the connections between training people
who are pro bolsonaro uh extremists and
Ada tactical now that's a whole other
story that's a stupid [ __ ] contract
they should have never taken yeah that's
a that's a whole thing that people
should definitely go look into and read
about uh anyway sorry about that well
maybe maybe we'll get into the um the
Insurrection in Brazil and who uh what
Americans are behind it uh but speaking
of insurrectionist
um did you see the video yesterday I
didn't play the sound but I played the
video of Marjorie Taylor green
um trying to use Dr Dre's music uh did
we get dinged yesterday for it no okay
all right well because I didn't I just
played the the very beginning
so he knew what song it was
um so people were aware but the good
liars here
um they made sure to do a version that
wouldn't be taken down with uh certain
audio uh a Marjorie Taylor Green Let's
listen to a bit of how the good liars
made sure that Margaret Taylor green
could play her video and it wouldn't be
taken down Q is a patriot we know that
for sure Hugh is trying to tell people
on these forums and 4chan and he's
trying to tell people the truth and he
does it through questions asking
questions asking questions and giving
Clues and so it's basically you know
you're going down the rabbit hole
according to him many in our government
are actively worshiping Satan and yes I
could dive into uh uh Kennedy getting
killed in the plane crash because isn't
it interesting that he had announced he
was going to run for Senate just before
he died in a mysterious plane crashes
but anyway so that's another one of
those
um Clinton murders right we had
witnessed 9 11 right we had witnessed
911 uh the terrorist attack
um in New York and the plane that
crashed in Pennsylvania and the
so-called plane that crashed into the
Pentagon odd there's never any evidence
shown for a plane in the Pentagon but
anyways I won't I'm not going to dive
into the 911 conspiracy I've got a
question for you you just did yeah Avid
gun owners and people that support the
Second Amendment to give up their guns
and go along with anti-gun legislation
maybe you accomplished that by
performing a mass shooting into a crowd
that is very likely to be conservative
very likely to vote Republican very
likely to be Trump supporters very
likely to be pro-second Amendment and
very likely to own guns is that what
happened in Las Vegas there's a once in
a lifetime opportunity
Take This Global cable of Satan
worshiping pedophiles now
you know I've got a theory about a pipe
bomber
um it's unrelated from this video oh
okay I don't even know why I'd bring it
up but uh I've got a theory about uh a
pipe bomber and uh I just I just find it
funny that she she was like I'm gonna be
so clever and then Dre was like yo no
[ __ ] about Dre you know like he just
came in right and was like look I didn't
snatched it I didn't snatch it away from
her I did not give you permission you
hateful bigoted [ __ ]
um and it really it really
it really is funny and telling and she
went on she went on to Twitter for sure
she was like oh it's uh the next chapter
whatever the [ __ ] she said she's like
because she got locked out of her
account and I'm like oh man remember no
she no she said you can't stop this and
then Drake right right yeah yeah yeah
which is funny because it's all within
Elon musk's world so you know you're
like ah free speech I want to use this
and then the person who owns it's like I
never gave you permission to do this uh
you can't just go you can't just go out
and say
uh that you know you can use my media my
song My you know artwork whatever and
and represent yourself with it because
um you're a novel person and I don't
like awful people doing [ __ ] with my
stuff one of the best parts about this
is it says it's time to begin and they
can't stop what's coming and they and
Dre immediately stops it right yeah
yes I can right but down here at the
bottom it's Kevin McCarthy and the House
Republicans are [ __ ] tagged to this
video that is [ __ ] hilarious it's
great
I well I mean but I mean it just it just
shows they're an aptitude it just shows
I look ridiculous there go ahead I love
that video have you seen the video where
it's an opaque version of the bomber
the the sandwich over Marjorie trade or
green walking why would you bring that
up is there is that that's the same
[ __ ] person yeah
they got the same again this exact same
there
that December video was like one why are
you having these meetings before you
ever sworn in
you two in your conspiracy theories look
I'm not gonna dive into 911 and the
connection of Margaret Taylor green
planning that event but
like that's the type of [ __ ] where
she's like oh I'm not going to talk
about the Pentagon and the play and this
it's like just like this you literally
just did you broke it down and said
these things and brought it up I'll do
it I'll do it I don't know um if the doj
is on top of Margaret Taylor green being
a bite bomber but um I think she is and
that's all that matters is I think she
is because that you know in the world of
Q Anon as long as you're thinking and
believe it it's true
um speaking of speaking of Q and honors
and troglodytes this [ __ ] idiot and I
know I keep beating this to death she
posted this video from her official
account
um and she said it's time for us to
deliver and I came across this [ __ ]
video today and again I'm gonna show you
this [ __ ] bonehead doesn't know how
to yield her time back on the floor but
of course it's full of lies but listen a
little bit Madam speaker the American
people have spoken they have fired you
and have chosen to end the Democrats one
party rule throughout our government the
days of this chamber being treated as
Pelosi's house instead of the people's
house are over okay so first off she um
she doesn't understand what a majority
is and that they have the slimmest of
majorities which means and and they use
gerrymandering to get there so she
doesn't understand like
you know the American people actually
did speak and the majority of them voted
for the minority but you know who's
counting yeah the American people will
once again
be allowed into
the chamber to see their representatives
at work
promises on the campaign Trail yeah you
sure did make good on Good Luck promises
we must defund the 87 000. there you go
IRS agents that the Democrats great idea
domestic
Oh you mean like
corruption and of course the big guy
who's at least compromised by 10 percent
reinstates men and women who were
shamefully discharged because they
refused to take the covid vaccine just
like they'd be discharged for refusing
to take any other vaccination secure the
southern border
at which there is a complete Invasion
and reduce the flow of China's fentanyl
into our communities Republicans Across
America ran on these policies watch the
end if we fail to deliver on them
without a yield
she doesn't yield she yields back God
damn it I just I can't stand this she
just she she yielded it and then it just
went and went right it's under the house
floor somewhere else right yeah she
doesn't yield it back to the chair see
this is this is this is what drives me
nuts about this this whole thing is like
most average Americans don't know the
the floor operations they've never
watched the house debate or Senate
debate on the floor
um it is very boring it's very dry
government's not supposed to be [ __ ]
entertaining folks it's really not it's
not supposed to be professional
wrestling it's supposed to be boring and
dry policy making is not supposed to be
you know how boring it was so I watched
yesterday's rules package vote you
wonder how boring it was they voted on
the times in which they could show up or
should show up on Monday and Tuesday
following a vote to you know extending
hours two hours before so they could
have debates this and that like that's
that sounds sexy
you know like I propose uh this
resolution to this bill right uh and
then they're like unanimously you know
we accept it right and that's the type
of stuff it is there's a bunch of
[ __ ] right we don't always get this
but you have to do those things for
government yeah exactly yeah I mean I'd
be like ass whatever but this bonehead
has been in it's been a congresswoman
for two [ __ ] years and she doesn't
know how to yield back the time to the
chair and it bugs the [ __ ] out of me
because the other day
um during the speaker uh vote she didn't
even she didn't even say I yield she
just walked away from the microphone
and the clerk at that Point's like yeah
this [ __ ] idiot she's not gonna do it
right anyway so she just takes that she
walked away from the microphone as the
process and it's not the process but
anyways I keep beating that horse but
the reason why is because what makes
anyone think that she'll get anything
else done if she can't even [ __ ]
figure out the words to give back her
time to the floor is to yield back her
time but whatever so you're telling me
the the the the
person that owned shooters
Bar and Grill that gave everybody your
mass diarrhea yeah might not be drafting
legislation no she won't she won't she
won't be reading legislation and that
72-hour period that 72-hour period that
they put in effect yesterday in the
rules where you have to wait for people
to read it she's not going to read it
either she ain't gonna read it you
wouldn't understand even if she even if
her name's on it she ain't gonna read
that [ __ ] well a lot of these rules I
mean a lot of the rules yesterday were
performative but also they were done in
a manner that protected their own party
right like
it really tells you the the the
Republican party you know as as ethical
as they are uh it's weird that they
would be the ones gutting the office of
congressional ethics right like the the
party that would investigate George
Santos and other oh they're so ethical
Gabe Sanchez they're so ethical that
they don't need ethics right committees
but I mean yeah Lauren bobert is another
example of someone she's a talking head
you know what she says isn't relevant or
is Justin because oh the other thing I
want to bring up too is so I watched I
watched the the points that were made
before the the vote and then I watched
the vote and then you know they went
back and forth on you know can we get a
count can we go to this can we get to
that you know obviously extending hoping
that maybe someone would budge or you
know they can they can push the vote out
um and actually fight it but yesterday a
lot of what was discussed was the same
thing they went back they're like oh the
gentleman from Arkansas you know can you
do this and it's funny though when they
talk back to each other like oh my
friend from this state they're not fun I
mean like a lot of these guys whatever
the cordial but they're not [ __ ]
friends but that's all the formalities
but that's the house decorum the same
way the house decorum is to yield back
your time right here but but yesterday
the things that were said was there was
nothing new that was said they brought a
couple people in on both sides from the
Ways and Means Committee but on the
Republican side it was more or less
regurgitating the same thing they're
like 87 000 people 80 billion dollars
this and this and that and they didn't
say anything new they just kept pushing
me ideas they're like 87 000 people are
gonna be voted then Democrats like thank
you for bringing that up let's just
clarify and debunk this right now 80
billion you take away adds 114 billion
but the problem was you were one of 12
people watching that happen so yeah I
mean look that's the problem is is the
government truly is [ __ ] boring and
it's going to be hard to get any
American to pay attention for longer
than five seconds that's the that's why
we in in this space need to [ __ ] can
mock them and and bring it to people's
attention as much as we can that's why I
show you she doesn't even know how to
the proper decorum on the house floor
and she's supposedly been a
congressperson for two [ __ ] years
oh
yeah
I'm listening to you I'm listening to
you yeah all that all that yep and yes I
mean it really I mean and what you're
saying is is absolutely true because
it's not a one-off it's continuous she
she has never followed decorum and the
rules of decorum are actually there for
a reason they invented them for a reason
but you know she's not gonna she's not
bright enough to figure those out she's
just never gonna do it well but she
doesn't respect not only does she not
respect the House of Representatives our
the people's house she doesn't respect
her office that she is holding and she
doesn't respect her [ __ ] constituents
that voted for her and then and she
definitely doesn't respect the
constituents that voted for her opponent
and she doesn't understand that she's a
[ __ ] she's a goddamn United States
House Representatives for a district in
Colorado and those people [ __ ] count
on that person and she can't even
[ __ ] manage to to just do how house
decorum properly it's not that [ __ ]
difficult for a congressperson to
operate into Quorum it isn't and it just
frustrates the [ __ ] out of me that
anyone would take her seriously and the
other thing too is some [ __ ] who
follows me on Twitter yeah I'm gonna
call him an [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
I always watch him he said Tony you're
platforming Lauren bobert you stupid
[ __ ] I'm pointing out the [ __ ] that no
one else will see yeah I'm platforming
her stupidity you dumb bastard yeah
listen this this idea that we can't we
have to ignore everything they say and
everything they do you are you are dumb
sons of [ __ ] if you think that that
their side isn't going to see the stupid
[ __ ] they're saying we have to know what
their plan is
I mean or lack thereof because we have
to communicate it too that's right to
the people that watch this show we have
to communicate it to them so when it
hits them they're not cold they're not
cold like there's this guy Corey Mills
is floor demand he's the new one of the
new people in Congress who's been
talking [ __ ] and saying the stupidest
damn things you know you talk about
bullshitting their own voters he he puts
a tweet out that says well we need to
pass a law that only oil coming from our
strategic natural reserves can only go
to Americans only Americans can buy it
well you have no [ __ ] clue how oil
markets work one and two if you in some
fantasy land
um did create a law that those Futures
contracts or those oil contracts could
only go to an American buyer you would
totally undermine the purpose of the
Strategic reserves which is to be used
to to moderate oil prices on a global
basis you know this isn't like a
stockpile in case we go to war or
something like that that's not what it's
there for it is a a throttle on global
oil prices and if you limit it only to
Americans you literally eliminate
the biggest tool you have to help
Americans out when oil prices Spike that
Congress who has some stupid
idea would go to I don't know experts on
the markets on the oil markets and oil
production to make sure their idea makes
any kind of [ __ ] sense before they
say it out loud well excuse me that's
the exact same thing that I'm talking
about here when I'm talking about Lauren
bobert doesn't even have enough brain
cells to [ __ ] just follow the Cur
decorum let alone represent her [ __ ]
constituents in a way that they should
be represented what's this link you sent
me game it's a video uh Caitlyn sent me
it's a video of a of a a creator that
did commentary on on what happened in
Brazil it's a pretty good deal I haven't
seen it yeah yeah okay yeah it's it's
not too long either but the other thing
I want to bring up here too is when
somebody says because I get those
comments too where like you know I'll
find a clip from Newsmax or something
like that that maybe somebody hasn't
shared or I'm sharing a clip that hasn't
been shared too much and I'm like hey
you know check this out Bring attention
to it yeah right you know like because
again it you know like Texas Paul said
you don't want to be caught like caught
off guard you don't want to be stuck in
a position where you say whoa whoa where
did this come from because you need to
realize that there's a pattern and
there's a behavior that they've set and
the other thing and with that in mind
you also have to realize that when you
say uh don't platform them if you want
to compare my my numbers which is like
60 000 followers on Twitter versus
Lauren bobert who has hundreds of
thousands not only that but is a
government official and isn't isn't is
featured on Fox News sometimes clipped
uh she was on you know the 11th hour
last week she made an idiot of herself
and I'm glad for it right
and it does legitimize what she's saying
which isn't the best thing but at the
same time it's like when somebody tells
me don't platform that person are you
kidding me I'm a nobody compared to this
person who's in office who does hundreds
of interviews over the course of their
career when somebody says don't platform
Trump are you [ __ ] kidding me the guy
was the president of the United States
he had a company he had a show he had
all this stuff me platform you're so
famous games
don't platform I'm like are you serious
my one tweet is not going to all of a
sudden make that person the The Talk of
the Town let me give let me give you an
example go ahead go ahead text ball and
then somebody says don't platform them
what they're really saying is they don't
understand how any of this works right
they don't get it you know it is
literally our job to take the stupidity
that these people put forward and
platforms because they have they have
they they have worked with guys like
Frank Luntz they've worked with
professionals to Wordsmith these
messages and put them out to have have
maximum effect on people that have no
clue what they are actually talking
about and let's be honest the average
American doesn't understand Global oil
markets so we have to inform them this
is being said this is why it's stupid so
when they're stupid ass crazy butt
[ __ ] chat Uncle shows up at their
house saying well what about them
Democrats and then oil prices they want
it we want to keep it for America
you've got an answer right they got to
understand knock that down in two
seconds here's the thing Let me Give an
example
um Joe Rogan has not been controversial
what in the last I don't know four or
five months Gabe there ain't been much
controversy around him yeah
but there was a lot of controversy
during the pandemic and soon after the
pandemic here's why Joe Rogan would
bring people on his show who would just
lie lie about the pandemic lie about the
vaccine lie about covet and he would be
like yeah yeah yeah uh-huh yeah and he
was platforming their views now if Joe
Rogan himself were sitting in that chair
going you're a [ __ ] liar that's
[ __ ] let me bring up let me bring up
some evidence of why that's [ __ ] he
would be platforming their stupidity
that's the difference you gotta
understand that talking about something
isn't [ __ ] perpetuating their idea
it's sometimes it's saying hey look at
this stupid [ __ ] and how stupid
stupid their ideas go tell your friends
how dumb this son of a [ __ ] is that's
the point if Joe Rogan during that time
would have been pushing back on those
people not just going yeah every dumb
idea that they came up with eat horse
pace and you know eat your own [ __ ] and
drink your own piss and whatever the
hell they were [ __ ] talking about if
he would have he if he would have
actually pushed back on them he wouldn't
have had the controversy frankly
everyone been like yeah good job good
job Joe Rogan and that would have been
it move on and his but the most
important thing is his audience would
have seen him actually chastise these
people for spewing lies instead of him
going yeah audience believe what they're
saying because I'm an idiot and I have
no idea what they're saying so you might
as well believe what they're saying
because I believe it
so yes it is platforming but the reason
and the intent and the context of the
platforming is super important and I
don't want you folks out there in the
pro-democracy Coalition not pushing back
on some [ __ ] rather it's your uncle
Chad like Texas Paul or someone in the
grocery store or someone at your PTA
meeting or whatever chat that's right or
in our chat right because we got a guy
in our chat right now named Sean Woods
that just put [ __ ] out there about
the price of eggs what really happened
with the price of eggs is we had a
disease run through our corporate
farming systems where they raise
chickens for both meat and eggs you
remember chicken was really high for a
while well it takes a while to replenish
replenish those stocks so now eggs are
really [ __ ] high and this [ __ ]
[ __ ] idiot douchebag dumb son of a
[ __ ] named Sean Woods is in our chat
talking about how the price of eggs is
Joe Biden
chickens [ __ ] diseases
he didn't you dumb [ __ ] that's
called Market pressures that's called
capitalism but this dumb [ __ ] is
gonna sit in our chat and think that
he's on the Joe [ __ ] Rogan show where
he can say stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] and
nobody's gonna call him not for being
the stupid [ __ ] idiot Maga simp dumb
bastard that he is oh well we know what
happens in these industries you dumb
[ __ ] idiot you're not on [ __ ]
Republican talk hold on we know what the
[ __ ] we're doing
Texas Paul are you telling me that
there's a thing called supply and demand
no get it get out of here equilibrium
with them we're supposed to be a
socialist country God damn it this is
called socialism hey Sean hey Sean
welcome he's very he's also very
obsessed with Joe Biden yes he is he he
must you must if someone needs to go
check on uh Sean Woods
came first the chicken or the egg then
I'll feed yeah there he goes Sean Sean
welcome to the Tony Michael's podcast
and I'd like to introduce you to uh an
uh an [ __ ] three of them one of them
being Texas Paul so thanks for uh
joining the chat uh don't say anything
stupid because the mods will [ __ ] ax
you you little [ __ ] but stick around
keep typing in that Trump copy machine
we haven't had someone since fake game
uh we've been dry here but tying that to
exactly what you're saying right exactly
what you're saying we have to get this
information out they say oh don't
platform that just means they don't
understand how any of this works
politically you're dead right Tony right
on the money 100 shut the [ __ ] up about
telling us what we can and cannot talk
about because believe it or not we're
actually [ __ ] professionals here I
mean there's a reason we knew what we
were talking about when we sat down on
this [ __ ] show because we're not Sean
jack off Woods who wants to sit around
and repeat some [ __ ] talking points
we actually have to dig a little bit
deeper to do our [ __ ] job so you know
listen I I don't know um that anyone
considers me a professional the way I
talk but you know it may I mean now now
here here's what I'll tell you
um speaking of platforming someone and
de-platforming someone did you hear
someone got de-platformed by coven oh my
God I am so upset it couldn't have
happened to a nicer [ __ ] lady on tell
you what um which one is it diamond or
silk I'm not sure which one kicked the
bucket here uh diamond oh diamond yeah
that's a shame who gives a [ __ ]
um you know the you know you know why
I'm gonna I'm gonna [ __ ] Dance all
over her grave you know why number one
number one because she is a pile of [ __ ]
and probably no telling how many people
this these [ __ ] idiots killed by
spreading misinformation about the thing
that killed her but here's the thing
they're [ __ ] fundraising off the but
the body isn't even gold yet and they're
fundraising offers so why why would
anyone gear if I dance on her [ __ ]
grave yeah [ __ ] her yeah
oh man Diamond I haven't known those Liz
about that boy you really got us
diamond is so so true that that
again and again and again and again
they'll do the dumbest [ __ ] it's like
when they bust migrants to vice
presidents uh Harris's home and then you
realize that oh just like the Martha's
Vineyard migrants those people are now
considered a crime I'm victims so now
they're under consideration for a
special Visa so so you mean so you mean
doing that made it more likely that
they'd stay here in this country is that
what you're saying almost
instantaneously yeah oh well God damn
and so this is another example where
you've got someone you know uh who who
which which I think the whole the whole
search for people who don't know the one
the person who broke the news on this
was Donald Trump and he wrote on truths
yes yeah that she died the family hadn't
even said anything yet
[ __ ] that's great that's great listen
listen
um you know you can judge me all you
want for again dancing on someone's
graveyard but you know what here's the
thing is that this person chose this
route she chose this that she chose to
make sure that she was not protected
when she got covered this is choices
that we made in our society and people
who choose not to get a free vaccine now
I'm surprised that she didn't get it and
just say she didn't get it like the rest
of these [ __ ] idiots I'm surprised
she truly is a dumb [ __ ]
all the rest of them did is got
vaccinated and say I'm not vaccinated
you shouldn't get vaccine I'm not
vaccinated just like the rest of them uh
blavaty which is a an online publication
uh they released an article uh around
Thanksgiving and they said
um they reported on this story about
Diamond being hospitalized or being sick
and they brought up that you had coveted
and they responded and they said this is
fake news it's not real she doesn't have
covid so then they took down the article
you can go on to Wayback machine you
could well here you could go into Google
you search for it you'll find a preview
link and then just go to Wayback machine
and you can look it up there
uh but what she did was deny they both
denied that this was ever a thing and
that she had coveted and I'm I'm sending
the link right now because this is the
response that long covet right she did
have I mean like it's the thing like
obviously she's someone who's more at
risk considering her health situation
but now easy how do you know her health
situation there
because she's dead
oh Overhill situation her health status
is dead is disease now I don't like
here's the thing I don't like to speak
ill of the dead but when you've got
someone who who potentially caused the
world of other people give a [ __ ] right
thousands of other people to die because
you spread you intentionally I mean
that's why Fox News had to drop them
people don't know this or maybe don't
know that she's more than just uh Mike
or was Mike lindell's uh talking puppet
on on Lindell TV but she got kicked off
Fox News and news information and news
and Newsmax and they're left to you know
just making videos on Lindell TV and
then well because because what they were
doing is they were syndicating the I
don't know what what it is it's like a
it's it's like a show that they just sit
and talk and say crazy [ __ ] sometimes
they interview yeah that that's the
whole point of it though man right is
that she's made they were making bank
off getting people sick and and getting
people they didn't but you know how
that's why I will laugh at this [ __ ] but
you know how much money so they got paid
they got actually uh for the person
Donald Trump who's about to break the
news before the family ever can say hey
our dear beloved Diamond passed away he
goes in here and says this but before we
read what what he says uh
try if you also look this up so they
were kind of Talking Heads for Trump and
they went to different places and said
oh yeah black community come to you know
support Trump all the stuff uh there was
one appearance they made uh they got
paid thirteen hundred dollars that's how
that's how much money down that's how
much Donald Trump respected diamond and
silk was like yeah how much how much did
Kimberly Guilfoyle get paid to go on
stage and introduce Donald Trump do you
remember I mean like how many lines did
you get to do I don't know well here's
the thing I'm not going to read this
statement from him I don't want to read
it just read it which part okay go ahead
you [ __ ] read it all right all right
okay I get tired of reading this
I'll I'll read the line all right I'll
read I'll read the line that really
matters here yeah Diamond's death was
totally unexpected probably her big and
Precious Heart just plain gave out
oh that's great that's great coming
that's the only line that matters listen
if you think if you think for a second
that me dancing on this grave is gonna
be someone off you are wrong because
when the Cheeto does q and honor finally
chokes on a [ __ ] Big Mac or or a
[ __ ] bucket of chicken boy I'm Gonna
Be Dancing on that grave for [ __ ]
weeks and weeks and weeks and weeks so
so if you're don't like me dancing on
Grays well you can just get the [ __ ] out
because I'm going to be doing it you can
goddamn dead yeah but you know what I
love about this I love about this and I
just want to tie this to our to the
people that watch our show the people
that follow us and support us pull up
that pull up that tweet if you can from
that follower of mine about the four
stages of covet
if you can pull that up this is what I'm
saying folks we read what you send us we
don't ignore you just come up here and
talk and then ignore you I think it's
the second one I sent you
okay maybe the first night I don't know
it's the four stages of covet but this
is from one of our followers man and
this is the kind of [ __ ] that is just
Priceless we absolutely love your input
on this because this is fantastic the
four stages of covet
yeah here it is okay
there's four stages covered it's a hoax
don't be a sheep
prayers needed and visit our GoFundMe
because that's exactly what's happening
today with old diamonds is they are
already Griffin they are already
gripping for donations
yeah I mean
I mean only unexpected and her heart
exploded from being so great and so big
she was so loving and caring so loving
and caring [ __ ] out of here her vegan
Precious Heart just gave just plain gave
out I mean talk about the most tone deaf
digital eulogy because you know we all
know Mike Lindell is going to be given
the eulogy at her at her at her uh at
her funeral right oh yeah but I wouldn't
be I I joked with someone last night I
said I wouldn't be surprised if this
group tried to say hey buy right now
twenty dollars fifty dollars hundred
dollars whatever and you can buy and own
a piece of diamond and I guarantee you I
guarantee they would like you know
there's those little lockets where you
can put like uh the the ashes of some
loved one in there you know yeah I
guarantee that they would probably go
get some sand and dirt put it in a
locket and then tell you that this was a
piece of diamond and then it would say
for 50 bucks
Mike Lindell is going to be at that
funeral and he's going to be like this
is a Mike pillow pillow in the casket if
you really love if you really love your
loved one buy them a my pillow casket
now available casket pillows available
today we're gonna call them the diamond
class casket pillow that is just for
your loved ones what's the promo code
there Mike what's the promo code
for the sale hey I got some breaking
news
um uh I don't know if you guys noticed
this but the Democrats are starting to
move on these uh Senate seats at these
um these Senate seats that are going to
be open in 2024 like a [ __ ] they're
moving on them like a [ __ ] um we've
seen in Missouri Josh hawley's seats
coming up in 2024. Lucas Koontz who ran
in a primary against
um Trudy Valentine or a bush uh who Bush
lost against uh Eric Schmidt our former
Attorney General of the state of
Missouri he's a piece of garbage I I
mean you're Republicans so what do you
expect but Lucas Koontz is going to be
running again for this uh for the Senate
but he's going to be
running against Josh Hawley hopefully if
he wins the primary but we have some
news here Katie Porter is going to be
running for the Democrats seat that will
be open in California uh here's the ad
we're living through a Time
of extraordinary change I'm Katie Porter
change can be electrifying and
exhilarating but change can also be
disruptive like the constant assault in
our democracy and the dangerous
imbalance in our economy
the threat from so-called leaders like
Mitch McConnell has too often made the
United States Senate the place where
rights get revoked special interests get
rewarded and our democracy gets raped
especially in times like these
California needs a warrior in Washington
that's exactly why I'm announcing my
candidacy for the United States Senate
in 2024. I don't do Congress the way
others often do I use whatever power I
have to speak hard truths to the powers
that be to not just challenge the status
quo but call it out name names and
demand Justice that goes for taking on
Wall Street and the big Banks big oil
and big Pharma it's why I refuse to
accept corporate path and lobbyist
campaign money I don't want it and I'm
leading the fight to ban Congressional
stock trading because it's just wrong to
win these fights it's time for new
leadership in the U.S Senate if you
agree please go to k babyporter.com and
join my campaign for the U.S Senate
today thank you for caring about the
California we can build
together
okay yesterday I talked about
um there's some people saying Katie
Porter and King Jefferson run for
president no they should not this is
exactly where Katie Porter needs to be I
would I I would love for her to stay a
congressperson forever but if this
senate seat comes up and Katie border
can win this senate seat and be on uh
committee's questioning and holding
accountable through the Senate the
United States Senate I am all for that
Katie Porter will make a great Senator
she will make great leadership she will
make a great Majority Leader one of
these days in the senate in our Senate
so I'm excited that that Democrats are
doing this thing where they're like you
know what [ __ ] it we're going to start
running we're not we're if if if this is
really going to be a two-year goddamn
cycle with this chucklehead down at
Mar-A-Lago let's start politicizing this
let's start running let's start making
bones let's start our narrative let's
start spending it let's make sure the
nation knows who is the adults in the
room and who want to govern and who want
to do policy making Texas ball
yeah you're gonna come to me okay
because I got to tell you
that man right there knows very well who
was going to fill that seat because
Dianne Feinstein is going to retire
early she is she's done wonderful things
with her career and I totally adore the
woman but she knows her time has passed
and she was going to step down from the
seat to give
allow the governor to appoint someone
she's been holding out because Gavin
Newsom has been signaling he's going to
appoint himself
and that's going to be the next phase of
his political career is to be a senator
Katie Porter brilliantly kicked him in
the Cooter over that because you know
she has massive Democratic support
especially out in California Gabe can
tell you more about this local politics
better than I can I will tell you but
that's exactly what this commercial
timing was all about was to get ahead of
Gavin Newsom you know building up a
consensus that he should be this is
where he needs to go after the
governorship
yeah I mean I mean the other thing too
is obviously you're you're working on a
on a group like Newsom that or a person
like Newsom where you know there's a lot
of debate like oh what's going to happen
in 2024 obviously what's going to happen
beyond that you know there were some
Rumblings of him taking over
tenancy there's Romance of him you know
running for president obviously we don't
see those things happening especially
with this I mean she because obviously
it would happen after you know 2024.
but the other thing too is like why
wouldn't you capitalize on a moment that
was captured right like again I said it
yesterday we are
we were we were less than we were a week
into the new year okay we're 10 days in
right now but somehow the photos of the
Year okay I'll say photos because it
happened at the same time I mean you
could say that there are the three but I
I honestly believe there are two photos
that are the photos of the year and they
were captured within a week of the first
year of this year happening which is one
you had uh two pay wearing Lego man Mike
uh Rogers going after
uh Matt gates for voting present and at
the same time the right is unable to
govern themselves
Katie Porter's reading a book The subtle
art of not giving a [ __ ] which I think
was a beautiful moment like you could
not write something better than that
better than that and who wouldn't want
to capitalize on that to be like while
this side doesn't know what the [ __ ]
they're doing and doesn't know how to
govern themselves let alone the country
I'm over here waiting waiting for us to
actually be able to get to work so I can
help you the American people right she's
like look boys sit down and and control
yourselves don't be so emotional
and let us professionals and us adults
actually do the job
at Texas Paul I'm gonna push back on you
in the game of Newsome thing because I
believe Gavin Newsom is going to do a
good job in California as he finished up
his term there and I believe that he is
poised to really step in to the race in
2028 now rather he's the top Contender
or not I believe Gavin Newsom will enter
that primary uh for the presidential
um race and he will enter it early
because he want he's going to want to
take up as much space as he possibly can
while Joe Biden finishes up his his
second term
um that's Gavin newsom's math here and I
don't believe him
um having two years in the Senate being
a senator especially if he appoints
himself is going to give him much uh
oxygen for that but I will say I'm not
opposed to either Newsome or Katie
Porter being in the seat but I prefer
Katie Porter over just about anyone in
any congressional seat and the one
reason why is because Katie Porter is a
policy maker and she's a serious policy
maker and that is one of the most
important parts uh about it now I do
want to play real quick before we leave
because I mentioned
I'm where the hell did you go I I
mentioned I just want to make sure that
we play the video
that I that I sent you before we go oh
well oh you talking about the bolsonaro
one yeah yeah okay okay we'll play that
one God damn no man for the record I'm
you're not arguing with me I could agree
with everything you just said Tony yeah
well it don't it doesn't mean Newsome's
not going to be stupid and try to take a
senate seat sure but but yeah I agree
with everything you're saying I mean it
only makes sense right Texas Paul you
should just always agree with I'd say
that's right
uh Newsome has had a pretty good career
in terms of you know uh uh
going you know going back from Governor
to Lieutenant Governor mayor like all of
these things like he's had a pretty good
career in terms of
uh
of leveling up one to the next like you
know part of me thinks obviously
you could debate like you could go into
Senate to continue that that governing
position but it almost feels like a
senate position would be a step down
right like you would you would
accumulate all of those wins as governor
and then the next yeah well you you want
to go from executive to Executive not
executive legislator executive yeah most
the time an executive who gets elected
to the the president United States uh is
from a governorship I mean there are
Senators obviously who do get elected
but they but most the time they come
from an executive standpoint you
wouldn't but but anyways here's here's
this video for the audience I have no
idea what it is so congratulations on
getting it on the show today
um let's let's watch respond because
we're running out of time so couple of
days ago in Brazil the far right decided
to sequel j6 like y'all need a new
[ __ ] move but the reason they did
this is because yes Steve Bannon gave
them the idea he's such a treasure but
here's here's the best part about the
whole thing
during the uh fake Insurrection some
dude decided to sell cotton candy
hey I love the opportunism
Brazilians work hard man yeah hey man
you got to get your [ __ ] Sugar Rush
on I mean Russian when you're storming
the [ __ ] Capital bill yeah you're
like oh what else are you gonna I mean
because Christ it is it is so perfect a
representation of how much of a circus
in a carnival that the far right
extremists are you go you show up you
raid the building
but you also can enjoy this cheap cheap
sugary uh yeah
and then what happens is they all get a
recipe before they can take uh right
there before they crash you know well
again Q Anon is a hell of a drug
um and this is a q Anon World we're just
living in it speaking of living in it
don't forget to subscribe here to the
Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube we're
gonna get to 20 000 before the end of
the month and we're gonna do it let's
just [ __ ] do it it's two years of
Tony it's it's 20 000. that's how we're
gonna frame it somehow I don't know
we'll figure that out we'll figure that
Texas Paul thanks for joining us as
always everyone remember if you didn't
get your Texas Paul Fix in today it's
going to be a few weeks he's going on
vacation so wish go to Texas Paul's
Twitter account go to his YouTube page
make sure to wish him uh a happy
vacation uh so he'll have a lot of good
memories I'm sure he'll be still sending
us videos and tweeting about all the
nonsense that's taking place you'll just
uh he'll just laugh each somewhere from
afar on the beach you know right it
would just be on a beach doing it
somewhere so thank you for joining us
today Texas Paul everyone thanks
tomorrow is Wednesday same time same
[ __ ] place Surf's Up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon